allez salut ça va alors les vacances
bien ou bien bien tant mieux parce que
c'est fini alors retourner à la mine
c'est sûrement pas de gaieté de coeur
c'est même peut-être un petit peu
stressant et ça va sans doute vous
causer des désordres de type digestif si
vous voyez ce que je veux dire tout
l'été des tc du talent et du non mais
non mais non vraiment c'est fini les t1
mes vacances tout ça c'est terminé c'est
la rentrée et justement tu suis un peu
dtc partenaire de votre rentrée quand on
prend le chemin de l'école du collège du
lycée du boulot de quoi que ce soit
qu'on avait arrêté de faire pendant les
vacances quand il faut y retourner donc
en plus de pas forcément être ravi ravi
ça peut arriver qu'on soit un poil
anxieux qu'on ait la boule au ventre
comme on dit sauf que la boule au ventre
quand elle sort elle a pu trop une forme
de boule justement
en fait le stress donne la diarrhée
phénomène également connu sous le nom
scientifique de la chiasse la drouille
la courante la dérive est là clichés en
spray l'intégrale des banques quand vous
êtes stressé votre corps le sang et il
va tout raconter à votre hypothalamus
alors hypothalamus n'est pas une chaîne
de restauration à base de grillades 1
c'est un petit coin de votre cerveau qui
pèse 4 grammes mais qui pèse quand même
extrêmement lourd dans le système
nerveux games pour se défendre contre ce
qui est perçu comme une menace votre
organisme va se mettre en mode commando
bon comme il connaît pas la nature
exacte du danger dans le doute il va
activer tout un tas de mécanismes pour
se mettre en condition idéale pour le
combattre ou pour s'enfuir
ouais faut de corréler un peu de rab
assez juste à rentrer lui l'envoi de dix
pirates
le juge est pas ça part d'une bonne
intention puis c'est pour votre bien
bon mais ce qui nous intéresse
aujourd'hui c'est la digestion elle est
gérée par système nerveux autonome et
elle va être touché principalement par
deux phénomènes d'avoir comme ils sont
menacés votre organisme va donner la
priorité aux organes qui peuvent
vraiment lui être utile comme votre
cerveau ou vos muscles au détriment
d'autres organes qui servent à rien
comme votre estomac la digestion ça
demande beaucoup d'énergie en a besoin
ailleurs et puis toute façon c'est
vraiment pas le moment de tout fait
hop on met tout ça sur pause pour le
moment du coup l'estomac ne se vide plus
c'est ce qui explique que vous êtes
peut-être l'appétit coupé voir une
petite envie de vomir
et une fois que ces coupes et là-haut
figurez vous que votre organisme se met
en tête de faire un peu de place en main
dans l'esprit de votre organisme qui ont
fait des caisses 1 rappelons le il va
falloir fuir ou combattre la cause du
stress
du coup on est d'accord ça va être le
moment d'aller faire caca
ah ben c'est maintenant la fin ça
n'arrange pas chef là je donc pour
éviter d'avoir envie de croquer au plus
mauvais moment votre corps décide de
faire la vidange est en réalité c'est
hyper facile à faire parce que vos
intestins
c'est pas juste un tuyau d'évacuation
passif vos intestins ils ont une
activité qui s'appelle le péristaltisme
part c'est pas une discipline olympique
le péristaltisme c'est le mouvement de
fond vos intestins pour faire progresser
le caca vers la sortie et ça ressemble à
peu près à ça donc en l'occurrence il
suffit d'accélérer le péristaltisme pour
prier les matières fécales d'évacuer les
lieux bon alors ok ça sort vite mais
pourquoi ça sort moussa sarr mouvoir
liquide parce qu'au début de leur grand
voyage vos matières fécales elles sont
chargés d'eau et elle s'en débarrassent
normalement tout au long de leur road
trip du coup en cas de stress comme le
voyage est beaucoup plus rapide
la moins de temps pour que l'eau soit
absorbée résultat quand votre caca sort
il est encore plein de flotte donc il
est tout mou voire franchement oui
malheureusement dans ces cas là ce
pourrait des médicaments habituels ça
sert pas à grand chose et ça risque même
de vous coller une bonne constipation en
guise de retour de bâton mangez léger
manger sain et attaquez vous plutôt à la
racine du mal
le stress pour ça vous pouvez faire
quelques exercices de respiration
abdominale pour vous détendre par
exemple attention la respiration
abdominale ça veut pas dire respirer par
le bar d'ailleurs dans ces circonstances
prenez pas trop la confiance
évitez de ventiler parlement mon conseil
ne surestimez jamais vos cinqueterre
vous explique au niveau de l'anus on est
équipés de petits muscles en cercle à
qui entoure le conduit pour empêcher les
celle de sortir à des moments
inopportuns
ce sont les fameux cinqueterre alors il
ya le sphincter interne qui est contrôlé
par le système nerveux autonome
c'est-à-dire qu'on ne maîtrise pas et
al'inverse le sphincter externe qui nous
sert à serrer les fesses comme on dit
sauf qu'en vrai on est d'accord on sert
pas les fesses sont serge juste la nuit
et justement parfois quand on est
vallonné on peut décider de desserrer un
petit peu son sphincter pour relâcher la
pression
dans ces cas-là ça s'ouvre un tout petit
peu juste assez pour laisser passer les
gaz mais pas trop pour garder les selles
normale à l'intérieur mais voilà là pour
le coup comme on l'a vu les selles elles
sont pas normales elles sont molles voir
liquide et du coup elle n'arrive à 100
et là c'est le drame bon pour être
pragmatique la règle absolue c'est si
vous êtes stressé
si vous êtes fragile à ce niveau là ne
pètent et sous aucun prétexte
d'abord péter un jour de rentrée ça fait
tâche et puis ensuite bassari de
vraiment faire tache voit la dtcc com
l'été c'est fini pour cette fois mais ne
vous inquiétez pas ça va revenir vite à
ça même revenir très vite parce que pour
moi aussi c'est la rentrée de seconde la
plus prochaine retour à la normale pour
une nouvelle saison d'été avec plein de
surprises mais ça on va en reparler plus
tard en attendant bonne rentrée et
portez vous bien